le poids des années comme le poids des
médailles n'ont pas altéré sa mémoire ni
son sens de l'humour assez de moutons
enfants du nouveau brunswick
edgar doiron s'est enroulé comme
volontaire avec le régime en autre chose
11e et des rwandais de tempêtes de vent
on pourrait pas interroger tarder
c'était pour la date prévue le 6 2 juin
1944 c'était plutôt le 29 demi ses
souvenirs de guerre sont lointains mais
bien vivant du débarquement en normandie
où il a été blessé en juin 44 à son
retour au combat pour la libération des
pays-bas il ya eu trop blessures de
guerre puis il y aurait peu revenez mais
a choisi de
continuer qui parle beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de la gare là l'horreur des
enfants comme vous ai dit que manger des
bulbes de tulipes pour mon respect c'est
ça l'à beaucoup marqué ça et quand
j'étais petit le lien par l'impôt
n'était plus réservé
au fil des commémorations et des retours
en europe edgar doiron semble avoir fait
la paix avec la guerre sur 40 ans
d'avoir fait quoi j'ai fait c'était
important de sauver du monde si tu étais
en santé
les employés de la résidence le du frein
tenait à souligner de façon spéciale ce
centième anniversaire
amie lily tine a déjà accompagné son
grand père vétéran en normandie et comme
enseignante elle a souvent invité edgar
douaron a rencontré ses élèves pour elle
c'est plus qu'un devoir de mémoire c'est
corrigé l'histoire telle qu'on lançait
nos jeunes en parlant surtout de la
conscription et on parle pas encore des
canadiens français qui sont allés à la
gare
puis il y en aura bientôt plus mais moi
j'ai peur que ses hommes la baisse
qu'ils ont fait ça tombe dans l'oubli il
reste moins de 200 canadiens encore
vivant parmi les quatorze mille qui ont
fait le débarquement en normandie france
ait jamais de mal à ma santé mais ça
passe assez vite si t'es pas malade
je suivais terrain fut retraités oui mon
garçon et infanterie du fis donc
la voir c'est vraiment cool de voir
où est ce que ce monsieur là c'est rendu
est surtout de savoir en plus de wii
vient mais c'est surtout le fait d'après
ici qu'on a des libertés que
malheureusement si je ne l'avais pas cet
âge là
avec deux ans ulrich jeter a exactement
le même âge qui est garé doiron avait
lorsqu'il est débarqué en france en juin
[Musique]
ici anne louise despatie radio-canada
salaberry de valleyfield